The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
This is how I picture Andre Rise and went to work every day when he played for
the Atlanta Falcons.
I don't even know who that is.
Just rolling it.
Well he's a pro bowl NFL wide receiver who spent just crazy money like 30 bloats
rolling and cars and shit.
Yeah,
like he blew through a lot of it.
He was on that broke um,
special that they air and he was just like,
if somebody pulled up,
you know,
and like a Ferrari,
you're like,
yeah,
that's just hot.
I got to top that shit.
So then he would go like the day,
that day I got the land by what the brains blown out man.
Like just to top each other guys would just buy shit to show off,
you know,
to compete with each other on it.
They say that there's some ungodly number of people.
It's like 80% of all NFL players or broke in bankruptcy within two years of
retiring.
It's,
it's incredible.
I mean,
you know,
the older I get,
the more I understand the younger guys having no like 0 million cents and also
zero if like financial Iq,
like they don't know the 21 they're like,
here's $3 million.
And they're like,
Ooh.
Yeah,
I can imagine.
It's crazy.
But it's crazier when they're like,
he played 10 1216 years like Iverson and he's blown through like $200 million.
And you're like,
I'm broke now.
Yes.
And how old is he now?
He's 37 something like that.
His body's not working right anymore.
Oh,
he's down of the NBA.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he's trying to play in,
but he's running through well into nine figures,
you know?
Wow.
I mean,
I,
you know,
and that's,
you have to consider,
he made a lot of endorsements.
So nine figures,
nine figures to make seven figures.
Yeah.
Girls would be like,
wow,
he makes seven figures.
It's like,
can't make nine nine I blew two.
It all.
Yeah,
that shit crazy,
man.
Woopsies it's crazy that
it's so much.
They,
they interviewed one defensive,
like a guy on the,
on the,
the special on the Brooke thing and he was like,
I don't know why man.
But he was like,
everybody had a car wash.
Okay,
we all had a fuck carwash man.
That shit.
That shit did not last.
Like we all spent money on a car.
We bought a car wash.
Yeah man,
you ain't got your own carwash.
And Bart Scott had the,
he was like,
you buy shit.
It's unnecessary.
He's not broke at all.
And he's still playing and he's like,
I'm smarter with my money.
But he's like,
you know,
everybody has a stupid purchase.
I bought a coat,
I think it was made a wolf.
Like I wore that shit once and it was like $35,000 you can wear a wolf collide.
I think man
Christ,
I get wolf coat.
That's admirable and you're loving it.
Look at you.
You can't be happier.
It's not possible to be happier than you.
I handle somewhere between that too pissed and somewhat pissed.
That's how you idle your bullshit.
You said that earlier.
It's like you saying that you're hard to work with.
I don't think I've hard to work that hard to work hard to change.
I bet your fight against someone trying to manipulate or,
or directly
do.
I remember,
I remember when we were picking for a jury recently about a year ago,
um,
and they were picking for a murder trial over in the Pasadena courthouse and the
Fellas is,
uh,
is there anybody here who isn't going to get themselves disqualifies there?
Anybody here who's qualified to,
uh,
try this case?
And I was the only one who raised his hand really.
So,
uh,
you know,
um,
I'm willing to listen.
And the guy says,
uh,
okay sir.
He says,
uh,
I think I know who you are.
He says,
um,
oh,
would you listen to everybody else's idea behind while you're deliberating on
this trial instead of certainly he said,
but you would try to convince them they were wrong if you had another idea,
right?
And I said,
yes,
that's accurate.
And you dismiss it.
Charismatic,
charismatic.
You had manipulated in your favor.
Well,
you're the lever.
Certainly not my one.
My first time in the Pasadena courthouse,
you know,
when our first time was Alex van Halen,
and I had to sue the Mayfield School of the holy child of Jesus Incorporated for
$125.
This was in 1975,
I think.
1970 625.
What was that about?
Well,
it was in a contract.
We had played a,
a,
a dance and in the one page contract it said there will be no smoking,
uh,
backstage.
There will be no marijuana consumed.
There will be no drinking,
et Cetera,
cetera.
And uh,
one of the sisters was nuns at the time,
claimed that she smelled pot smoke backstage and a refused to pass our hundred
and $25 for the band.
So agree.
Bitch,
was he she right?
Well,
no,
there was no pot smoke,
but she,
she's made it up.
She may have smelled Marlboro's actually those were Campbell Campbell filters.
But,
um,
uh,
Alex and I went and we bought a clip on ties so we could fool the judge and we
tied our hair back and we went to small claims court and filed.
Did you win?
Um,
well,
what happened was,
uh,
sat in front of the judge.
We sat on one side and on the other side,
uh,
two sisters,
two nuns came in and a family,
a father,
a mother,
and three of daughters in school uniforms.
You know,
they played it up hard.
And,
uh,
the judge says,
why or who filed here?
I said,
sir,
I did.
He said it was $125.
And uh,
there was no smoke,
there was no smoking of anything illegal backstage,
whatever.
And um,
he had the,
one of the nuns stand up and she said,
I refused to pay him because I smelled marijuana smoke.
And,
uh,
the judge says,
what is your answer to that?
Sarah?
And I stood up and I said,
sister,
how do you know what marijuana smoke smells like?
$125 later
paid for the t shirt.
Yeah.
How would she know?
I've heard you saying that you believe that consciousness is nonlocal.
Alright,
what do you mean by that?
Well,
out of discontinuity.
See,
you are already familiar with this.
Continuated now you want to know even the most,
most unfamiliar,
most intriguing,
you know,
they said this is like Voodoo.
This is really like Udo,
this,
we're now getting into fail cracks up.
The most surprising thing in quantum physics that surprised you when Einstein,
Einstein,
and his whole life could not believe this concept of nonlocality,
which he himself discovered with two other physicists,
right and wrong.
How did they discover it or how to discover just theory,
you know,
and standing what the tour addition,
he never,
well I shouldn't say never.
They probably did experiments in his young days when he was a graduate student.
I did talk,
but tourists don't do an experiment.
No.
What they do is this,
a creative exploration of the mind.
By that day they find new ideas,
new ideas,
and then the,
then the predict stuff.
So Einstein's idea was this was 1935 mine.
Do I understand?
The idea was that if quantum objects took quantum objects interact,
they become correlated.
And this is a new word that he used in that paper.
He and his collaborators,
Rosen and Podolsky.
Um,
these people that really sound in with their theory,
their mathematics,
that if two objects once become correlated,
they,
even when they are not interacting,
even if they move away from each other,
even then they can communicate,
not in the usual way,
not interacting with signals,
then that still shrill.
You and I are interacting right now,
but we are interacting to a complexity of sound waves and electrical wires to
this microphones.
That's all true signals.
But these objects communicate without signals.
So their communication,
he was as a medium that can only be outside of space and time because in space
and time,
Einstein himself gave us the theory of relativity,
which says that nothing can interact without exchanging signals going to space
and time.
But these objects,
quantum objects,
one scar related,
they have the capacity of signal less communication.
This is what is called [inaudible] local signals that local going to space
taking it.
How do they,
how do they measure that these particles are communicating?
So the key is in that they measure the communication and the soul,
that there is no signal because the communication took place faster than the
speed of light in all local signals going to space and time must travel either
at the speed of light or less than the speed of light.
So if something can be shown to travel faster than the speed of light,
it has to be local.
And this is a 56 loud discovered into laboratory Atlanta stay in 1982 finally
verified by Einstein was dead long time ago around 10 55 so he never knew that
he's teary will one day not only prove to variety,
but really the evolutionize,
the whole world of physics by bringing in concepts of consciousness,
the Joe Rogan experience
[inaudible].